so we've got trig ratios I want to
transition into t-nut trig functions
trig functions are awesome we just saw
how many different kinds of applications
that they have right in real life in
indiana's okay but I think we've all
kind of forgotten because we've all
grown up with these me included how hard
trig functions are to do you win yes
super hard to work with okay and the
only reason why we can deal with them
sort of you know casually is because we
have this frizzes go ahead turn on if
you're in degrees mode function
something like sine 23 okay sign to me 3
and it gives you faithfully this decimal
right and you're like huh that's cool
and you pump it into you're working and
then you just go on your merry way
working out where that project I was
going to land okay but how did this
calculator note that that's what sine 23
is right for that matter how did know
house what sine or cosine or 10 of Amy
ankle is right well a human had to teach
it how to do that and that's really hard
because all computers can do basically
is addition it's all they can do just
really really fast ok so how do we get
from addition to like all of this
business okay well you know how I showed
you that that's a set of errors before
counting addition structures etc okay if
we start if you've got addition then in
the same way that those concepts
progressed before addition can be
extended to multiplication right I mean
the first time you met multiplication
was just as the idea of repeat addition
we now know it's more than that
you can you know you can add x like 2.5
or negative 3
maybe PI whatever it's like well I can't
add that a number of two and a half
times but multiplication is not scaling
not just in addition place where it
starts if you have multiplication what
happens when you've got this idea of
repeated multiplication
repeated multiplication its indices
right exponents squaring and once you
develop this idea of powers and
exponents right where that goes I don't
see individually but we have all the
pieces we need then you've got
polynomials okay because think about
what polynomials are the x is just a
number and you're combining the but
adding some
acting multiplying dividing and indices
it's all you need okay so Paula knows
that's why we've invested so much time
over the last 13 years trying to boom
towards understanding these things
because they're awesome okay polynomials
are actually what we use it's what's
what your calculator is doing every time
you hit sign cause 10 anything it's
pulling out a polynomial because
polynomials the right kind of
polynomials are really really good at
approximating trig functions in fact
they're also good at approximating trig
functions that you didn't even notice
that this is not a trig function it's a
polynomial it's just a particular
polynomial that I've picked that will
wave around in this particular way to
imitate how sine works okay so in
working with drug trig functions
what unnatural gonna try and solve with
you is how do we turn a polynomial into
looking like something like this which
for all intents and purposes is going to
be sine or cosine of town okay because
the way works I want you to remember all
the way back to when we did ready
measure and we developed some results
that will help us differentiate
indirectly do you remember that we said
for small values of theta we could do
some constructions inside a circle to
Radian measures start to say that theta
is basically equal to sine theta do you
remember that and it's also pretty much
equal to tan theta for very small values
of theta okay so the idea is if I write
this like with X's instead of feelings
this is saying that in a very particular
neighborhood right this polynomial this
is just the simplest point where there
is my warning you have just numbers but
this isn't you know after that it's a
symposium yet this polynomial for all
intents and purposes is this guy if you
have small enough X that was one thing
okay now we can extend this idea by
trying to get just just draw for me a
little Wiggly thing
all right if you think about what sign
looks like and you think at what y
equals x ok you can see the whole point
is grating one at the origin yeah it
does if I just like cover up these parts
here you're like how's the bad like it's
that's leaning away as you get closer to
x equals pun - but it's pretty good for
those small values if they are right
well what would I need to change how I'm
going to adjust this thing so it would
look a little more like sine X I I need
some turning points right and surely I
would benefit from having the turning
points here right cuz you know trig
functions they kind of have an infinite
number of turning points so for example
it's that an X right what if I put in a
parabola well if I put in a parabola
system right
so for example we could fashion a
parabola that looks kinda like this
right that'd work
I guess I'd get a turning point so that
mean I hit two of the R it's not just
one that's kind of useful right that's
good but it's still a long way to go
right I want well what am I gonna have
to do to get this closer and closer and
closer
I need higher powers denied right
because my apalis means two things
number one it means most stationary
points and it also means more roots
right like you know X to the N in theory
should have and roots right I mean you
know once you add other kinds of turns
in that country now this is a bit tricky
this is a tricky but if you take in know
I'm going to show you this picture I'm
not sure this picture here's what I
prepared earlier
oops that's fine perfect
we got make my mind up with this screen
gunner okay now have a look at this have
a look at this
that orange want that really is sinus
okay that really cynics and what you can
see here is what kind of degree is this
this is this is a cubic right that's why
it goes off that way in this way and you
can see it's getting pretty close right
if I were to actually that for a second
if I were to have a higher degree like
say this right have a look at that I
haven't added you know more little more
turning points but what I have done is
I've got not close up to where the where
the stationary point where the
intercepts are supposed to be okay and
if I add a few more that's gonna this
one okay you can see I've got more
wiggles and then up to a certain point
this purple one is the one I showed you
before that none of you are like oh yeah
of course but if I just zoom out a
little bit just a little bit you're like
ah that's so you can see you know I said
smooth ER right well if you're willing
to mess with this thing then you can
make that theta as large as you like and
just just just zoom back in again and
everything is fine everything is happy
okay